MALE SPEAKER: I'm
here today with Yale
to talk about his
medical device company.
What I learned from Yale
is that you can't really
quantify hustle.
And this guy, he really
knows how to hustle.
Right?
He is good at it.
So without further ado, I'll let
Yale-- the hustler-- Zhang come
up here and tell you
about his product.
YALE ZHANG: Oh, man.
Thanks.
Hi, Alvin.
I don't know.
I was going to begin today,
talking about vital signs
monitoring, but I just want
to say, I would-- everybody,
give him a hand for his
speech because I don't know
if I can live up to
the hype that you just
described because wow.
OK.
Anyway, so everybody,
my name is Yale.
And my company is
called Safe Heart.
And I'm here to talk to you
about vital signs monitoring.
But before I do that, let me
just show you what we make.
So it's an actual product.
It's called the iOximeter.
It's a vital signs monitor--
a pulse ox, actually--
that's powered through the
headphone jack on your phone.
So I'll talk more about
the technical details,
in a little bit.
But first, let me
begin with a story.
So we came out with the first
prototype, the first working
prototype for that, near
the end of last year.
And I really wanted to
show everybody, wow,
what a great product it was.
So I took it with me
to a Christmas party.
A lot of my friends were there.
A lot of new people were there.
And I passed it around.
And everybody wanted to try
it, to get their vital signs,
to measure their vital signs.
But there was one person there
who really got a great use
and benefited from
the iOximeter.
And that's Maggie.
So Maggie is actually
a friend of mine.
She's an artist and a musician.
And she was at the party.
So when she measured her heart
rate and her oxygen level,
using the device, we found
that the reading was actually
extremely low, that her
oxygen was in the low 90s,
and that her heart
rate was around 47.
And so she was concerned.
And I tried to make
it not as serious.
And I said, you
know, I mean, maybe
if you were an Olympic
athlete or you were asleep,
that's the kind of heart
rate that you'd get.
But she was actually
concerned about it.
So she called her doctor
and made an appointment.
And two weeks later,
they did a full work up.
And they found that her
medication that she was taking
for her insulin condition
was actually causing damage
to her kidneys, and
that, had they not
caught that at
that time, it could
have led to kidney failure.
So the good news is that
they adjusted her medication,
and that she's doing
a lot better now.
And so she was the first person
that had used the iOximeter
and actually benefited from it.
And now, now that our
product is on the market,
I get phone calls every
week from customers
who call and say that
they had some condition
or they were using it
to monitor in some way
that they're able
to benefit from it.
So back to vital
signs monitoring.
What I'm going to say today
is that, in the future,
within the next few years,
all of our vital signs
are going to be available
to us everywhere we go.
And that's because the
computational power
of the mobile handsets
that we have right now,
the mobile phones
that we have, are
going to be increasing
exponentially.
And when that
happens, a lot of what
used to be done in
hardware is going
to be able to be
redone in software.
And so we're going to be able
to have a lot of peripherals,
attachments, and wearables.
And you've already seen
that now, you know,
with the Nike Fuel FitBit and
other kinds of the [INAUDIBLE]
and other kinds of monitors.
But what we're focused
on at Safe Heart
is we are focused on the
vital signs, the ones
that the doctors care about.
So let me get a show of hands.
How many of you have
heard or have seen
or know what a
pulse oximeter is?
OK.
That's actually a lot people.
Cool.
OK.
Well, for the rest of you,
here's a brief history lesson.
So in 1972, two
Japanese scientists
discovered that
by shining lights
of two different frequencies,
a red and an infrared,
through your finger, you're
able to derive the heart rate
and the oxygen
saturation in your blood.
And that is the principle
of modern oximetry.
So later, companies,
such as Nellcor,
would come out with these
devices, like the N-100.
It's great.
It has a digital readout.
It's got alarms.
It'll tell you, of your
vitals, if the measurements
are too high or too low.
One problem is it's 25 pounds.
So it's not a very
portable device.
And that's where my
background comes into play.
So I don't have a
background in health care.
I don't have a
background in medicine.
And my background is
actually in logistics.
In fact, my second startup,
called Clinical Guard,
is actually a low-cost medical
devices distribution company.
Though, actually, the main
product that we're known for
is actually a $1
low priced THC test,
to see if you've been
smoking too much.
All right.
And it's very popular
in UCLA, actually.
That's actually one of
our biggest customers.
So anyway, so I do get customer
phone calls on occasion.
So in 2009, in the
fall-- that's actually
a picture of the
phone on my desk--
I had a call from a customer
who bought one of the lower end
pulse oximeters that
we were selling.
And it was an elderly lady.
And she said that though
she liked our product,
she couldn't use it because
her eyesight had gone bad,
and that she couldn't read
it because the display was
too small.
And so I said, well, what would
you suggest as a way for us
to make the results shown
to you much more easily?
And she said, what if you could
show the results on my phone?
And I said, you mean
like a phone oximeter?
Is that what you're telling me?
And she said, yes.
And I thought, wow,
what a great idea.
So I don't know how
many of you have
seen the movie
"Inception," but it's
kind of like waking up from
a dream, where I woke up,
and I said, wow,
that's a great idea,
I want to make an
oximeter for the phone.
So for the next three
years, I put together
a team, funded mostly by my
own savings, to come together,
across multiple continents,
to make this device.
So what I wanted
to talk about, now,
are the four goals,
the four founding
principles of Safe Heart.
And the first one
is reducing costs.
So what that means is that over
the last few decades, as we've
seen, the cost of health care
has gone up tremendously.
And thanks to the
Affordable Care Act,
the cost has been in
control, slightly.
But our goal is to
reduce the costs.
So if you think about how
plasma TVs-- actually, that
is a bad example, they're
not being made anymore.
If you think about how LCD
televisions are continuing
to get much larger, and the
prices either stay the same
or drop, I thought, why can't
we do that for medical devices?
And there's no reason.
There's no reason
why we can't do that.
The next thing is
open access of data.
So what that means is that
before, your doctor read
your chart, and they told you
their interpretation of it.
But what if you could have
access to that data, yourself,
and make informed
choices and make
informed choices from there?
The other important thing
is that increased access
and validity.
So what we're doing is we're
opening up all of our hardware
to third party developers.
And we're going to
allow them to create
apps that run from there.
So increased access--
I'm sorry, increased
accuracy and validity.
What that means is
that-- so, for example,
before, one of the problems
that had plagued clinical trials
is that the population
that they studied on
was homogeneous, which means
that the results of the derived
might have been skewed because
of the small study set.
Now, because of the
deployment of our device
and the fact that the app
can gather information
from every single user,
we're able to have
much finer granularity,
when it comes to data,
so that we can make much more
intuitive and educated guesses
as to the trend.
So, for example, we
can use it to study
where if someone is living
downstream from a power
station, is their
oxygen level going
to be lower because of that?
Now we can actually test that
by deploying these devices out
in the field.
So the last thing, like I
said, was the app ecosystem.
Well, unlike some
wearable companies
that make their devices,
ours is going to be open.
So we're going to
create an open API where
you can export all of the
data and you can actually
access and activate the
hardware and integrate the data
into whatever you're working on.
So we want to be creative.
But I know that there's a
lot more people, especially
people in this room, who
are extremely creative,
who are already
having ideas on what
they want to do
with this device.
So now, talking
more about the past.
There's an old Chinese proverb.
I know you've heard of it.
It's probably been
used to death.
It's called, a journey
of a thousand miles
starts with a single step.
Well, for us, it was actually
a journey of tens of thousands
of miles.
And the reason for that
is because, well, we first
came out with it--
I'm sorry to say that.
When we first came
out with the device,
it was made for iPhone only.
We came up with a solution
that used the 30-pin.
And during that time,
Apple said, no, we're
going to switch everybody
to the Lightning jack.
So we contacted
Apple, and they said,
oh, yeah, you can use
the Lightning jack,
but you're going to give us
this much money to license it,
and you need to pay us
for every single device
that you use the
Lightning jack for.
And I said, well,
you know, our goal
is to reduce the cost
of these devices,
so how are we going to reduce
that if we were paying a tax
to use that plug?
So I said, uh, maybe we
could do something else.
And so I said, well, let's use
the headphone jack, instead,
because up until now,
every single phone
has a headphone jack.
And for the foreseeable
future, they probably
will have headphone jacks.
And the best part
about that is now we
can have a cross
platform device.
So that seems like
a simple idea,
but actually, it set
us back an entire year.
Because there's a
limited amount of power
that's coming from
the headphone jack,
we had to make two
breakthroughs, one
in power consumption.
So the original device
that we came out with
used 120 milliwatts.
And the new device
that we have today
uses only eight milliwatts.
So we reduced the power
consumption by over 95%.
The other innovation
that we made
was in data compression so.
If you use the square or other
kind of credit card swipe,
the data rate for that
is of only about 1k.
Through compression
technology that we developed,
we are sending data
back at about 20k,
so back to the phone.
So that's why, now,
we have a device that
works both on Apple
and on Android.
I didn't want to
infringe any trademarks.
So we were using that picture.
OK.
So during the development
of our product,
something else happened.
It's the Quantified
Self movement.
So starting with
companies like the FitBit,
they're creating
devices that are
used to measure
everything about you.
You know, how many steps
you're taking per day,
how far did you
run, how many left
turns you made when
you're on the highway.
Those things are good.
And in fact, if you take
a look at the two images
here, that's actually a
map of all of the friends
I have on Facebook.
And so that's part
of Quantified Self.
And we want to contribute to
the Quantified Self movement
by creating actual
devices that monitor
the vital signs and
the same vital signs
that doctors have been using,
for decades, in the treatment
of actual health conditions.
So we can contribute
to the, in addition,
new measurements
that can be taken
while you are going about
your everyday lives.
Hold on.
OK.
Now, we're a small startup.
And like I said earlier,
it was mostly self-funded.
So we don't have a huge
marketing campaign.
But we did try to do
some viral marketing.
And so here is one
of our viral ads
that we released last Christmas.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Honey.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, baby?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you
want to have some fun?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Wait.
I just want to be safe.
OK.
I'm ready.
YALE ZHANG: OK.
Yeah.
It is a little bit risque.
And believe me, there
was a huge backlash
from the nursing
community, telling us not
to advocate unsafe acts at home.
But the good news is, I mean,
we have over 30,000 hits.
It seems to be pretty popular.
And the people who are
forwarding it mostly
are people in health care.
So I think the message
that comes across
is that unconventional thinking
and developing these products.
We want to put that
message out there
in not just our product,
but also, in our ads.
So let me tell you what I
like about the iOximeter.
Well, if you take a look at
the exterior design up here,
it's actually designed
by my friend, Simon Li.
He was actually a friend
of mine from college.
His background is
industrial design,
but he's mainly known for
bathroom fixtures, which
is great because you
would take a look at this,
and it doesn't look
like a medical device.
It wouldn't be out of
place on your coffee table.
So what I also
like about it-- we
don't have any
proprietary ports,
which means that you can
use it with most phones.
And the other thing is
that when you use it
with a different
operating system,
if you want to
switch out phones,
you're always going to
have a headphone jack.
And I do a fair
amount of traveling.
And the last thing
that I want to do
is carry a charger with
me, a bunch of chargers,
a bunch of cables with
me, everywhere I go.
Well, with the
iOximeter, because it's
powered from the
headphone jack, you
don't have to worry about that.
You just have one device.
You plug it in,
and it just works.
And so back to what
I was saying earlier.
This is how pulse
oximeters used to look.
And this is how the
iOximeter looks now.
So I'm going to
give a quick demo.
All right.
So my friend Lauren is going
to come over here and show you
how this works.
All right.
So what I have here is a S5.
But you can also use
it on the phones that
are produced by
the other company.
All right.
So what we have here
is the iOximeter app.
It's started.
And OK.
Are you ready?
LAUREN: I think so.
My heart's beating a
little faster than normal.
YALE ZHANG: All right.
All right.
So OK.
I'm going to try to
show you right here.
OK.
So basically, the
iOximeter app, it's
available on the Play
Store and the App store.
It's gathering the
measurements right now.
This is what's known
as a plethysmograph.
And it's actually a
chart of the heartbeat.
So Lauren's a very
good friend of mine.
She actually came down
here, from Atlanta,
to help support me on
this talk right here.
But she's also the person who
told me about Maggie, earlier,
who introduced me and
Maggie, and also Alvin,
and everyone else in this room.
So she's a great
social connector.
She's also involved
in a kickball league.
And we're on the same team.
So that's the story there.
OK, good.
So we have the measurements now.
So what you're
looking at is actually
a new version of the app that's
not available in the store.
But we're going to be
releasing it this week.
There's actually two
functions that are new here.
So what we have here, on
the upper left-hand side,
the oxygen saturation.
On the upper right-hand
side is the heart rate.
So it's actually
dropped significantly
from where we started measuring.
So--
LAUREN: Meditation.
YALE ZHANG: Are you doing
that meditation breathing?
OK.
All right.
So the next thing is, on
the lower left-hand side,
is profusion index.
And that's a measurement of
the strength of your pulse.
And on the lower right-hand
side is a brand new measurement,
too.
It's respiration rate.
And this is an improvement
from the app version
that we had just
a few months ago.
Here's some other
functions that I'm
going to show just very quickly.
There's a chart
right here that you
can use to zoom in and
look at the results.
There's a summary
that you can use
to look at all of
the measurements.
And then there's a
settings right here,
where you can set
the alarms for when
the values are too
high or too low.
All right?
And then, OK, so
now Lauren's going
to just walk around the audience
and show everybody the device.
OK.
All right.
Yeah.
Originally, we were scheduled
to have an Elmo projector,
but it didn't happen.
So we're going to improvise.
All right.
So what you saw
on the app was it
had the heart rate
and oxygen saturation.
It had alarms to tell you
when the heart rate was
too high or too low, when your
values are too high or too low.
It's got recording
and the ability
to target your
results over time.
We're actually working
on an exciting project
with Wolfram
Research, where we're
going to be able to export to
their new programming cloud.
You heard it here first.
All right.
And then the new functionality
is the respiration rate
and the profusion index.
So a new functionality that
came out for this app-- this app
is free.
All you have to do
is buy the hardware.
And we're continuing to
develop new function for it.
We're going to release
new updates for it
every few months.
So one of the things
you're going to ask-- well,
how am I going to make
money on this thing?
Why would I continue to
make new features for it?
Well, one of the biggest
inspirations for me
was actually a
company called Nest.
So two years ago, my
air conditioner broke.
And as a part of that
new system that I got,
I also got one of
these thermostats.
And I only had to buy it once.
But through the two years
that I've been using it,
its function has
improved, and they
have continued to come out
with new features for it.
And that's really been a
big inspiration for me,
where we're going to make
a device that you only
have to buy once.
You don't have to keep
buying a new version of it
every single year.
You just buy it once.
And we're going
to continue making
new functionality and
new updates for it.
And here's an analogy
that I'll give.
And it might be an
analogy that might
be too old for some of
you in the audience.
So when I was
younger, I remember
watching a movie called
"Charlie and Chocolate Factory."
And part of it, when they
made the factory tour,
there was a candy called
the Everlasting Gobstopper.
And one of the parents
that was on tour
said, well, if everybody
has one of these,
aren't you going to
stop selling candy?
Well, that's fine because we're
going to do something else.
We're going to make
other cool things.
All right.
So what was
inspiration for that,
and why are we doing it
in an unconventional way?
Well, as I said, my background
is not in health care.
It's not in medicine.
It's actually in shipping.
So one of the other
inspirations for me
was actually a guy by the
name of Malcom McLean.
He was a person in 1934.
He bought a secondhand
truck for $120.
And over the next
20 years, he was
able to build a
trucking empire that
became the fifth largest
trucking company in the US.
But he wasn't done yet.
He wasn't done yet.
At the time, the
law forbid someone
who had a trucking company
from owning an ocean shipping
company.
But he had a really,
really good idea.
So before his idea, when
you needed to ship something
from let's say New
Jersey to Miami,
you could either use trucks
or you could pay longshoremen
to load things, piecemeal,
into a cargo ship.
Well, his thought was
that, why don't we
have cargo ships using
a standard container?
So it took a decade
of his life, but he
was able to convince
every single shipping
company to switch to a
standardized 40 foot container.
And by doing so, he was able
to reduce the labor costs.
He was also able
to reduce theft.
And he was also able to
reduce the time that it
took to load things and
also, ultimately, the cost.
So he reduced the cost of
shipping a ton of freight
from $5.18 down to $0.16 per
ton, a 97% decrease in cost.
And so that's why,
every day, now, we're
benefiting from
that because we're
getting everything shipped in
here from China, via container
ships, at a very
inexpensive price.
So back to the drawing board.
We came up with the iOximeter.
And now that you've
seen it working,
you know, you're going to
think, wow, it's really cool,
I want one.
Right?
I thought so, too.
So we came up with the product.
We went around to retailers.
We explained to them, this
is how the device works,
and this is why you
should carry it.
Well, the first question that
major retailers, like Walmart,
asked me was, why would
anybody want a pulse
oximeter on their phone?
And my thought was, why not?
So rather than sitting
there, in their office,
and trying to convince
them otherwise,
we decided to go
a different route.
And that's why I
was here today--
to make that introduction.
In the middle of
last year, I suddenly
discovered a thing
called crowdfunding.
And I said, wow, isn't that
a great way to sell products?
So even though we already
had a product working,
nobody knew about us.
So through a fortunate
series of events,
we entered into the Insert
Coin contest over at Engadget.
They selected us as
one of the products
to go out to the
show in New York.
And after that, we launched
our crowdfunding campaign.
And I will tell you this.
I am not a social media guy.
I barely use Twitter.
In fact, I had only sent
one tweet my whole life,
before then.
So there were a lot of
things I didn't know.
So that's why Alvin, who I
have hence called the crowd
whisperer, he was a big
part of our success.
Although, I didn't listen to
all of the advice that he gave,
and we probably would've
funded a lot more,
had I taken all of
the careful steps
and planning that we'd done.
But regardless, we
had a 60-day campaign.
The goal was $10,000.
We raised a little
bit over that and were
able to pre-sell 188 devices.
So that's the good news.
So the campaign ended, we had
this money, and I thought,
wow, this is cool, we're going
to go make this product now.
Wrong.
OK.
We've never manufactured
anything before.
I don't have a background
in manufacturing.
So we ran into a bunch
of different challenges.
The first one, communication.
Well, when someone backs
a campaign on Kickstarter
or any other kind of
crowdfunding platform,
they're personally
invested in this product.
So it's important to make
that person feel important.
It's important to
make them happy.
And I wanted to make sure
that they were happy.
And the important
thing to do that
is if you encounter snags
or production problems
along the way or setbacks, that
you would tell them about that.
Not what we did.
So that's an important lesson.
The second thing
was manufacturing.
Did you know that
according to Pantone,
there's over 1,000 different
shades of white for plastic?
When we were making the
printed circuit boards,
we had a problem where
they wouldn't fit.
We had to figure
out new adhesives
to use that wouldn't
melt the plastic
and would also be
strong enough so
that you could use it
for years without having
to break the device.
And just, there's
a host of issues
that we wouldn't know until we
actually started making things.
So there's a huge difference
between a prototype
and an actual finished,
commercialized product.
And finally, shipping.
Well, I'm standing
on stage today,
but to let you know this.
Did you know that after
the New Year is over,
there is an additional,
separate Chinese New Year?
Because that's important to me.
So once we had made
the devices, and they
were sitting on the dock,
ready to be shipped out,
Chinese New Year happened.
And so, for two weeks, everybody
took a holiday in China,
and nothing was coming
in or going out.
So we were sitting here with
angry voicemails, emails,
and even a carefully
written, handwritten letter
from one of our backers,
asking where their product was.
And there was nothing that
we could do about that.
So it's important to plan ahead
and set realistic timelines
for when you're going
to deliver the product.
But the thing is, there are
important lessons that we
did learn, though, and
things that really helped us.
So first is getting
the word out early.
So next time we run a
campaign or we come out
with some new
product, we're going
to listen to Alvin's advice.
We're going to start
several months before, talk
to the right people, get
the PR machine working,
and then just get
the word out there.
It's not about making a great
product or great products.
Yes.
And you think, great products
will sell themselves.
But it's really about marketing.
And you might know
that, since there's
a lot of marketing dollars
being spent on products that you
buy right now.
Next thing is talk to
anyone and everyone.
And you know, that's the thing.
And I actually
want to thank Ben,
who's in the audience today,
about that because when Ben was
in town on Easter, he needed
a ride to the airport.
And he said, can
anybody give me a ride?
And I said, OK, I'll step up and
drive him down to the airport.
And so during the
ride down there,
he asked me what
I was working on,
and I said, oh, I came
out with this iOximeter.
He said, wow, that's
a really cool product.
You should come down
and do a talk at Google.
And so that's why
I'm here today.
So that's just one
of the examples.
But you know, everyone
I've spoken to,
even if they don't have
the same background as us,
or they're not in
our industry, they've
been able to offer
new perspectives
and give us great insights
to make improvements
to our product, to our
app, and also, to the way
that we're marketing and
selling these devices.
So it's always important to talk
to everyone who you know or you
don't know about what
you're working on.
Don't keep your ideas a secret.
The next one is build
a group of super fans.
So how many of you
know who that guy is?
OK.
All right.
He's Stephen Wolfram.
He's actually the creator of
Mathematica and Wolfram-Alpha.
He actually came by our
booth, and he saw our product.
And I showed it to
him, and he said, wow,
that's really interesting.
The next day, somebody
from that company
called us and said that,
yes, we want you to work,
want your device to be sending
data to the Wolfram computing
platform.
I was like, wow,
that's-- really?
So it's not just him,
but through crowdfunding
this product, we were able to
develop a core base of what
I would call super fans,
20 or 30 people who we gave
early access to our app,
who can help us find out,
to give us feedback.
And as they're using
the app, they're
enjoying their day
to day activities.
And they've helped us
improve the performance
and functionality greatly.
And that's the other
benefit that we've
gotten from crowdfunding.
So who are our
primary customers now?
Well, we have pilots, who are
general aviation pilots who
may be flying in
uncompressed cabin aircrafts.
And they are looking
to avoid hypoxia.
And also, high altitude climbers
who also want to avoid hypoxia.
And also people who
are professionals
who are interested,
young people who
are interested in monitoring
every aspect of their health
as they want to
improve their fitness
or just to go about
their daily lives.
And so this picture, I'm
actually most proud of.
It's an image of every single
iteration of our device,
from the first version
to the current version.
So, as you see, there
are 13 different designs.
There's actually a black one.
Yeah, that was a one-off,
because I was thinking maybe
we could do a black one
with like a red cord
and then have like the
heart beats edition.
I don't know if Dre
would like that.
Anyway.
So yeah.
That didn't happen.
But that's where we are.
We are manufacturing
and selling this device.
We have signed up two
major distribution deals
with the two largest
pilot and aviation
catalogs in this country,
Sporty's and Pilot Mall.
And we also continue to sign
new distributors every week.
So this is where I like to talk
about the next exciting thing,
which is our partnership.
So when I told you earlier
that all of the vital signs
would be available to
you in your future,
well, there's a team in Oxford
University, headed by Dr. Gari
Clifford, who has been working
on this for many years.
So while we were busy
working on the iOximeter,
they have been working on
a host of other devices.
And so I'm glad to announce
a partnership with Professor
Clifford, where he
will be able to offer
the expertise and the knowledge
and also the technology
that their team has developed.
And here's just one example.
So the blood pressure
team, right now,
consists of five
guys, [? Mauro, ?]
Marco, Carlos,
[INAUDIBLE], and Ali.
And they're from
all over the world.
They're working in a
laboratory in the UK,
right now, on blood pressure.
And they're working
on something that's
very, very extraordinary.
But before I show
you what that is,
here is a quote from
Professor Clifford.
So he says that "we are aiming
to slash the cost of health
care equipment and transform
the landscape of competition
into the service-delivery
and software sector.
This partnership with Safe
Heart will accelerate our time
to impact and allow us to focus
on improving and designing
new technologies."
He's basically saying that
we're on the same page,
that we both want to create
affordable, low-cost devices
for everyone in the world,
not just people that are here
in this office or in this
building, but everywhere.
So one of the first problems
that we're going to tackle
is actually blood pressure.
So as you may know, as people
from the Baby Boomer generation
get older, and as people's
quality of life increases,
one of the side effects
of that is increasing
the number of people who
have high blood pressure.
Well, there are blood
pressure monitors
that you can buy right now.
You can go to CVS and get one.
But this new device
that they're working on
is going to be much
better in many ways.
So if you take a look, that's a
picture of the current design.
It's a small circuit board.
It's a USB adapter that
fits on your phone.
And it can fit inside
of a Tic Tac box.
And what that makes
is this device.
It's a hand-pumped
blood pressure
monitor that you can
attach to your phone.
And why are we
using a hand pump?
Well, there are motor-based
blood pressure monitors out
there, but they're
actually fairly inaccurate.
So by using a hand pump,
as in a sphygmomanometer,
where-- yes, that's right.
Gamification.
That's what it's all about.
So they made it
into kind of a game.
But by using a hand
pump, we're actually
able to increase the
resolution and accuracy
by a factor of three.
So this is what we envision the
final product will look like.
And the best part
is we're going to be
able to have the product
available very soon.
Now, currently, you can buy a
smartphone-based blood pressure
monitor.
They are out there
on the market.
And their prices generally start
from anywhere between $6,220.
This device is going to be
retailing for less than $30.
AUDIENCE: All right.
YALE ZHANG: So, what next?
Well, one of the problems
that still concern developing
countries is infant mortality.
And it's mainly because of a
lack of health care workers,
a lack of facilities and
proper prenatal care.
Well, one of the
products that we're
going to be working
on now is what's
known as a fetal Doppler.
So from this early
prototype, we're
going to make a smartphone-based
ultrasound Doppler
that expectant mothers can use.
And it's going to look something
like this, where you can just
put it on the stomach,
it'll measure the heart
rate of the unborn child, and
it'll display it on the screen.
And you can also record
a 10 second audio clip
so that you can send it to your
doctor or grandma or Instagram.
So whatever-- OK.
And we expect the retail
price for this device
to be less than $50.
So what I'm saying
is that we're working
on a lot of great technologies.
And through our
partnership, we're
going to come out with
a lot of cool things.
So we're going to
make a sporometer.
We're going to make an ECG.
And basically, what I'm saying
is that what we want to do
is we want to turn
this, which you
see in hospitals,
into this, where it's
a device, a host of
devices that can attach
to your tablet or your phone,
where all of your vital signs
will be available to
you, at your fingertips,
everywhere you go.
Now, I'm not the only person,
and we are not the only team
around the world,
working on these devices.
There's dozens, if not hundreds,
of teams, around other research
universities, trying
to do the same thing.
And it's good.
It actually creates a
market for this product.
But there's one more thing
I want to talk about.
And it's we're in partnership
with Professor Clifford.
It's the Buy-one,
Give-one program.
So, starting today,
until the end
of October, every
single iOximeter that we
sell on our official website,
for every single one,
we are going to give
one to a charity
organization in the third
world, or you can also
select a charity in
the US that would
like to use one
of these devices.
So everyone would
be able to benefit.
So that's why I
want to leave you
with these final thoughts,
the four tenets of Safe Heart,
and also, our partnership
with Oxford Center
for Affordable Health Care.
It's to reduce costs so that
everyone can have access
to the latest technology
without having to pay hundreds
of dollars for them-- to
open the access of the data
so that everyone
can make informed
decisions about their
own health care--
to increase accuracy and
validity through new analytics
that we're developing, based
off of the data set that we're
going to gather from these
devices and from these apps--
and finally, to create
an ecosystem of new apps.
So I'm sure some of you here
are interested in trying
this device out and seeing if
you want to remix it and make
something cool and new for it.
Talk to me after the talk.
OK.
So now I just want to give a
thanks to our team-- Simon, who
I talked about earlier, who did
the exterior design-- Alvin,
who did the PCB-- Herbert, who
was instrumental in creating
our apps so, unlike some
companies who came out
with their device for the iPhone
first, we were able to come out
with the app for both iPhone
and Android, simultaneously--
and then, finally, Gera, who's
responsible for developing
our user interface, a website,
and also, our packaging.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
YALE ZHANG: And then,
also, I just wanted
to thank Maggie and Dave for
letting me use their story.
It was just something that
really resonated with myself
because to see someone who can
benefit from something that you
created, something that
changed their lives
and improved it for
the better, that's
the most rewarding
part about what I do.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So, but you did
forget to mention your target
market-- the adventurous
couples-- right?
You didn't mention those.
So--
YALE ZHANG: I think
people already got that
from looking at the viral graph.
So I think--
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So the first question I had
for you, when I met you,
was, this is basically
a pulse oximeter, right?
And it almost seems too obvious
to connect to the phone.
And I think you had a
pretty good explanation
or pretty good argument of why
that wasn't necessarily so.
YALE ZHANG: Well, actually, if
you think about it this way,
you would think that having a
pulse oximeter on your phone
is a pretty obvious
idea, and it is.
It is.
But let me tell you a story
about another really obvious
idea.
OK.
So in 1980, Proctor and
Gamble had a huge problem.
They needed to create
a new cleaning device.
They wanted new
cleaning technology
that would save people time.
So their internal team
developed a more absorbent mop.
When they put it out
in the test market,
the problem was they found
that people were spending
80% of their time
cleaning the mop,
rather than cleaning the floor.
So they hired an outside company
called Continuum Research.
Continuum Research spent
another three or four years,
hundreds of hours
videotaping people
while they were cleaning.
They were doing studies.
They were taking pictures.
And they still couldn't
come up with a new idea,
until the leader of
the team, Howard,
in a frustrated,
exasperated sigh,
he said, why don't we just
track dirt into people's homes
and see what they did?
So it was during
one of these visits
that an elderly lady, just
like the elderly lady that
called in one day and gave me
the idea for the iOximeter,
an elderly lady saw
that they had tracked
coffee grounds onto her floor.
So she went to her kitchen,
took a paper towel,
dabbed it with some water,
bent down, and wiped the floor.
And when Howard
saw the video, he
said, well, I must have
done that hundreds of times.
I must have done it
hundreds of times.
What if I created a
paper towel that I
could put at the end
of a stick and then I
can use it to clean my floor,
and then, at the end of that,
I could just throw
that paper towel away?
Well, that became the Swiffer.
So nowadays, it's a $500
million a year product for P&G.
And if you think about
it, a paper towel
at the end of a stick,
that's a pretty obvious idea.
But until someone comes up
with that, though, you know,
it's not been invented.
MALE SPEAKER: I like it.
So tell me about-- you said
you are sharing data, right,
for making it public?
So I know there are lots
of rules and regulations
about how you can access
and share this data.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about how you're going
around those rules?
YALE ZHANG: OK.
Well, the important
thing is that
when you're talking
about information,
about health and vital
signs, such as HIPAA--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
YALE ZHANG: OK.
When you're talking about
guidelines such as HIPAA,
one of the requirements
is that the information
has to be private.
Well, if you are using this
device on a opt-in basis,
and you are selecting to
share this data with whoever,
then you are actually in
compliance with the law.
But more importantly, when the
data's stored on the phone,
it's stored on an
encrypted database
so that their partners
can't have access
to it, unless they
are given permission.
MALE SPEAKER: And what
are some of the uses
that you can see for
making this data public?
YALE ZHANG: Well,
one of the things
I mentioned earlier was that
we can make educated guesses
and, actually, studies
about conditions
that people live in, and
also, have gathered more data
about that.
So, for example, let's
say I live downstream
from a coal-fired power plant.
Is my breathing
affected by that?
Well, if there's a
significant population
base who is using
this device or we
deploy this iOximeter
in a population,
then we can actually measure
their performance, over time,
to see if that's effected.
So that, and also, for example,
with the fetal Dopplers,
there would be ultrasound
Dopplers that we're developing.
We're going to be able to
say, does the sleeping pattern
of the mother, or
their stress levels,
impact the health of the baby?
Now we're going to be
able to gather information
on a much more larger scale.
MALE SPEAKER: Gotcha.
So what are some of the other--
you showed us a few products,
but are there any other
products which you're currently
working on?
Can you tell us about those?
YALE ZHANG: Yes.
Well, you've seen all
of the other products
that we've come up with.
But one of the things
that we want to do
is create an information hub
where all of these devices
can be plugged into so
that they can measure
all the vital signs,
simultaneously.
And then it'll be syncing to
your tablet PC wirelessly.
So that would be
the ultimate goal,
a patient monitor that you can
use at home on your bed stand.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So I think you've
shared your prices,
and you've shared basically
everything you are doing.
Are you not afraid that other
people now have, basically,
a benchmark that
they need to beat
before releasing their product?
YALE ZHANG: Well, I mean, this
talk is going to be on YouTube.
So the ideas that
I talk about today
are going to be out there.
But the way I feel
about it is that we
don't have to be the ones
that make all of the money.
If someone comes out with
something like ours that's
just as easy to use and is less
expensive, they should do that.
They should take these ideas
and make it so that, in the end,
it benefits the great public,
where everyone can have access
to it.
So one of the
inspirations for me
was actually Elon
Musk, who recently
talked about releasing his
patents to the Tesla motor car
to other automotive
competitors so
that the proliferation of
electrical car technology
is going to increase.
And speaking of Tesla, one
of my greatest inspirations,
and somebody from your country--
MALE SPEAKER: Right. right.
YALE ZHANG: Nikola Tesla--
he gave all of the patents
away that he even
worked on, just so
that we would have things like
AC power and induction motors.
So they can knock
off our products.
They can copy our designs.
It doesn't matter, as long
as more people have access
to greater technologies, at an
inexpensive price, that they
can use to improve their
end results, overall.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
AUDIENCE: Isn't iPhone getting
rid of the headphone jack?
YALE ZHANG: You
know, I was thinking
someone was going to
ask that question.
Yeah.
So there have been rumors.
And I've seen that there had
been some intellectual property
filings stating that they're
going to be developing
a digital audio converter
that uses the Lighting jack.
So with their recent
acquisitions of Beats by Dre,
then it's possible
that in the future,
they're going to get rid
of the headphone jack.
So when that happens,
though, we already
have a Plan B, which
has always been
Plan B from the beginning,
which is bluetooth.
I personally don't
like bluetooth
because that means you'd have to
bring another charger with you.
And that's just
another thing that
have to carry around with you.
But bluetooth is going to
be an alternative that we're
going to use if it comes
down to that, where we can
no longer use the
headphone jack.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
earlier in the talk
that your team had developed
some breakthrough technology
in your profession
[INAUDIBLE] about.
And what are your
general thoughts on that?
YALE ZHANG: Actually, we are
making that information public.
It mainly has to do
with time division.
So just think about how-- I
don't know how old everyone
is in this room,
but a long time ago,
when you wanted
to go online, you
had to use what's known as
a modem, through your phone.
And so we had what's
called Dial-up.
And so we were
using time division,
which is similar to what modems
used, to compress the data
and send it back to the phone.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned that you've
used the [INAUDIBLE] something
by 90-something percent, right?
YALE ZHANG: That's right.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So tell us a
little bit about that.
Like, what did you do to
reduce the [INAUDIBLE]?
YALE ZHANG: OK.
That's a good question.
I'm going to give away a
little bit of our secret sauce
right here because we
didn't even file it.
We didn't even file
a patent for that.
But what we've done is we
took the circuit board,
we identified which components
absolutely needed power
and which ones did not.
And so, as you're
using the iOximeter,
even though the light
is on all the time,
the rest of the circuit board
is actually turning on and off
10 times per second.
So we have a 10
Hertz on-off cycle,
where we actually use capacitors
to charge it up, and then
turn on the entire board, only
briefly, once every 10 times
per second.
And then we'd turn
it off again so
that you can set the
power, as opposed
to going full
power all the time.
OK.
Well, once again, I just want
to tell everyone my name's Yale,
and that's me in the corner.
This is Alvin.
Lauren was the one who helped
just demo the app for everyone.
Maggie and Dave--
it was their story,
in the beginning, that
really impacted me.
And also, if you use the
coupon code "Google,"
you can get 20% off when
you buy an iOximeter.
And like I said, it's
fortunate that I'm here
to give a talk today, but
there are many other companies
that are making devices
similar to ours.
So prepare to see a lot more
vital signs-based monitoring
devices showing up in the
marketplace, in the future.
[APPLAUSE]
YALE ZHANG: Thank you.